what Sean Strickland did that was
brilliant was while Sean Strickland was
the aggressor he was also a lot of times
the counter puncher meaning he he would
go and he'd wait for Izzy to do
something and then he'd capitalize not
even is he throwing a big shot or
throwing a jab but he he would
capitalize on all that and Izzy couldn't
get his awkward timing down because you
gotta think out of all the training
Partners is he has he doesn't have
anybody like Sean Strickland you know
that awkward style that weird Philly
shell with no leg kicks and I think what
else Sean Strickland did well the meat
and potatoes wins so I think Sean
Strickland went off a jab and a straight
right and great footwork and distance
control and just a pace that would melt
most men in that first round when he
when he wobbled him that gave Sean
Strickland a confidence knows he
belonged I think for Sean Strickland
having success in that first round was a
big issue for Izzy and also is he's like
oh man I'm gonna I'm gonna fight here I
mean he never got it going after that